- Welcome back to Understanding Quantum Information and Computation.
My name is John Watrous and I'm the Technical Director for
Education at IBM Quantum.
This is the seventh lesson of the series and in this lesson we'll discuss the phase estimation problem and how we can solve it
with a quantum computer.
We'll then apply phase estimation to the problem of integer factorization, which we discussed in the previous lesson.
What we'll obtain is Shor's algorithm, which allows integers to be
factorized at polynomial cost or in polynomial time if we prefer
to think in terms of the time required rather than the number of
elementary operations we need.
This is the crown jewel of
quantum algorithms in some sense, and while factorized large integers
may have limited utility for most people, it remains one of the most
compelling pieces of evidence that we have for the hypothesis that quantum computers will
offer striking advantages
over classical computers. Here's an overview of the lesson.
We'll start with a definition of the phase estimation problem itself, and then we'll discuss a method for solving this problem
with a quantum computer.
We'll take it one step at a time, beginning with what you can
think of as a kind of a warmup.
In the phase estimation problem, the goal is to approximate
a certain real number and in this warmup part
we'll see how we can get
a very low precision
approximation to this number.
This isn't going to be
good enough for factoring when we apply our solution to
the phase estimation problem to integer factorization,
we're actually going to need a pretty high precision approximation, but it's nevertheless useful to begin with this sort of a warmup
just to get a sense for
how the whole thing works.
We'll then discuss the issue of how we can get more precision, and this will lead very
naturally to an operation known as the Quantum Fourier transform.
We'll see exactly what this operation is and how it can be implemented
with a quantum circuit.
And once we have it, we'll be able to apply
it to phase estimation to come up with a general procedure for solving the problem
with very high precision.
Then in the last part of the lesson, we'll see how a solution to
the phase estimation problem allows us to factor integers efficiently.
And specifically what we'll get is Shor's algorithm for
integer factorization, or at least something that's equivalent to Shor's algorithm.
The way that this works is that we basically give
ourselves a stepping stone, which is yet another problem called the order finding problem.
And in particular we'll see how we can solve the order finding problem using the phase estimation procedure and then we'll see how
we can factor integers
by solving the order finding problem. We're going to begin with a special case of a theorem called the Spectral theorem,
and specifically we're going to focus on what the theorem tells
us for unitary matrices.
The spectral theorem is
a very important theorem from linear algebra and
functional analysis.
It tells us something interesting about how certain linear mappings can be expressed in a certain form, it's often called a
spectral decomposition,
that's useful for many reasons.
And like I said, we're going to focus on what this theorem tells
us for unitary matrices.
The spectral theorem is
more general than this. It doesn't work for all matrices, but it does work for a class of matrices
called normal matrices, which include all unitary matrices as well as some matrices
that aren't unitary.
But just to keep things simple, we'll restrict our attention
to unitary matrices for now because that's all we need for
the purposes of this lesson.
Here's a statement of the spectral theorem just for unitary matrices.
Suppose that U is an
N by N unitary matrix.
What the theorem says
is that there must exist an orthonormal basis of
vectors, psi one through psi N,
along with N complex numbers
Lambda one through Lambda N, all lying on the complex unit circle so that U can be expressed
as we have in this equation.
This is called a spectral
decomposition of U, as I've already mentioned, and it can be very convenient to know that U can be written in this way.
It can sometimes be convenient to have these vectors and these numbers when we're working with
a particular unitary matrix U, and it can also be very
useful simply to know
that such an expression is always possible as a way of proving certain things about unitary matrices for instance.
In this statement of the theorem, each of these numbers,
Lambda one through lambda N, is written in a particular way
as E to the power two pi I times theta where each of the thetas
theta one through theta N is a real number, and
we'll come back to this way
of writing each of these
numbers in just a little bit.
An important thing to notice
about these vectors and numbers is that each vector psi
K must be an eigenvector of the matrix U with
corresponding eigenvalue lambda K.
Which means that if we
multiply psi K by U, what we get is lambda K times psi K.
So what U does to each of these vectors is simply to multiply it by the corresponding number lambda K.
In general for some arbitrary vector, this won't be how U works, but eigenvectors are special.
And what the theorem tells us is that there is in fact
an ortho normal basis of these eigenvectors.
This equation down here by the way, follows from the expression that we have for U from the theorem, together with the fact that
the vectors are orthonormal.